jd just spent 180 dollars on a box of
baseball cards
and that's where i go nuts this is where
i go nuts because
i've said to jd take that there it is
that's 180 bucks
that could have been put in just a
long-term investment and i know you say
oh big deal 180 bucks but that 180 bucks
this is what all these guys say
that adds up it adds up it adds up you
keep putting a little money in
i understand when i hear a guy a guy at
jd's means is spending
seven hundred dollars on baseball cards
which is what he has spent this year
wow he's been close to seven hundred
dollars on baseball it's not just
not just baseball it's not just baseball
i got some nice cards too
we'll see what happens nice cards his
cards are his investment however
well they're part part of an investment
possibly yes
jd look at what you're looking at you're
looking at your future through baseball
cards you're spending an inordinate
amount of money on baseball cards as if
you're going to hit some kind of lottery
to me that's like playing the lottery
you should be taking the 700 the 700
should have been invested
in a mutual fund or something well i
i will get a financial advisor and uh
need figure financial advice but for now
uh i'm not like doing it
you know uh i went through a couple
weeks where uh you know
i was almost in a break a day but uh
what's a breakthrough he was
putting money into these card breaks
every day how much have you made doing
that
how fun it's entertaining to me i don't
know but he's not buying
he's not buying individual cards what
you're doing is what a break is and i've
never done one and i'm not gonna do one
but a break is they take out this box
and they're like oh this is a unique box
it could have these valuable cards so
you put
money in and you get a slot in the break
and so jd
doesn't know what he's gonna get which
is part of the fun for him i guess
listen that's mostly what i watch now on
tv like i'm barely playing madden
anymore because i'm watching
the car breaks howard he's obsessed
to the point where [ __ ] that box that
box that he bought behind him he texted
me he's like
hey you want to watch me
you want to watch me open up the cards
that's what he said yeah
and i did well he did yeah oh of course
i did what did he find
in that box the one valuable thing he
should show him the card with the
uniform jd
he got a card that actually
has a small piece about this big
of a uniform from a player
that oh my god something someday oh
whatever
listen i got a i got a i got a nice reds
card you know
that's a like a special uh you know
worthless shut up
howard these things are worth nothing
it's like i got a bunch of rookie cards
so we'll see what happens with these
guys
the chances are they're not going to be
worth anything jd so do you
on a regular basis stare at the cards
and
look at them i mean what do you do no
but no but i made piles over here
stuff that might be worth money one day
uh you know and then i i
uh i thought about doing something uh
hanging some up or something for
a design i don't know jd take your
[ __ ] money
and call robin she's good with investing
put it in [ __ ]
put it in like one of these mutual funds
or right robin what
do you what anything would be better
than what he's doing with it i mean
give me her no well yeah i'm not giving
him my number but
you